[Music]
hey hey Ana
I'm not going not now not ever
why didn't you say this to me when I was
alive my husband died we never got a
note
[Music]
hey it's Hannah Hannah Baker holy [ __ ]
settle in because I'm about to tell you
the story of my life
more specifically why my life ended and
if you're listening to this tape you're
one of the reasons why
this is a wild game of survival is
hidden telling the truth don't believe
everything you hear
whatever Hannah thought she saw she lied
about it on this taste but she's a crazy
drama queen who just killed herself for
attention and has secrets mrs. Baker
Hannah's secrets are what killed her
maybe I'll never know why you did what
you did
I can't if you understand how it felt
you don't know the whole story what else
why I need to know you're just like the
rest of them but I'm not everyone is
just so nice until they drive you to
kill yourself sooner or later the truth
will come out this is why game of
survive
Clow that's right why did you come to
build it you know those life experiences
that people talk about cam here
people who travel alone are using the
SAS or something